it's time for roses and Rosie in France
oh just sweep play croissant just sweep
ladies la Oh LaBelle all froze you guys
i'm lauren zima thank you so much for
tuning in to the bachelor in France now
I took French in high school and so I
came arms here tonight with many amazing
phrases such as javac Luba schnell just
really bibliothèque Giada loose out the
back but you know turns out I don't
remember any my high school French and
then this man never fails me our
resident editor JC my partner in crime
and crime tells me that he speaks fluent
French are you freaking kidding me
and also he speaks fluent French just
because he took French in high school to
[ __ ] how do you remember that how so I
will have JC say a few of the things
that I have been wanting to say
JC I'll play I'm like The Bachelor
tonight janessa and Shonda Lewis elevate
there would be a freaking thing I
I love French bread I like cheese Hamas
and I love rose a mere lil Jose this is
the best song from sassy principality
this company did you present it Fast
Company air comes to the America here I
don't know what you said but I trust you
to speak for me Thank You JC
wow that's great look at him in a blazer
so professional so stunning I'm gonna
have friends just a kiss we are in
France establishing shots of family
finally something romantic finally when
long hair back I said just to spend time
with Ari and to kind of keep that spark
burning like this is the perfect place
to do it
yes that's real Fort Lauderdale did not
feel like a beautiful city to fall in
love with Paris I'm on board with but
where they are staying
I am NOT on board with you guys what was
this boat I'm thinking we're in Paris
we're gonna stay in some beautiful
antique hotel and really see the city no
they put them on a boat and it wasn't
just any boat it was what looked like
some kind of wartime nuclear like
submarine about to deep dive all painted
black camouflage into the ocean send off
the bombs
what was this boat look at a Paris man
thanks food on play hard Ari says to
Chris Harrison quote I think it's gonna
be such an amazing week and it's been
really amazing some this far but wow
even Chris's face is like
yet hymn of thesaurus I know we say
amazing on this show a lot this I have
these great dates you know with Becca K
for example I was like I had an amazing
date and I was like okay been re talks
to Chris about all the amazing days his
hat and I finally realized what I think
part of the problem is here it's been
very hard to distinguish between our
ease relationships amongst the women who
does he really like who does he not it's
hard to tell I think it's because our
ease only looking at the dates he tells
Chris you know I had an amazing date
with TIA and an amazing date with Becca
and they're all amazing it's not about
the dates it's about the person and you
have to think about the person he's not
really distinguishing the woman's
different personalities he's just saying
all the dates are great and so it's hard
to tell hello Bonjour then Chris says
Bonjour to the women and crystal in a
moment of self-awareness says she's
pretty sure she's gonna get the
two-on-one this week but then she does a
complete 180 on that self-awareness and
says I'm such a obvious choice for the
jaalin target on my back since my mom
won just Chris don't know that Arie
picks the women for the dates like the
other women aren't picking you for this
two-on-one because you would target on
your back there's just no one on my
level like to compare
I was saving the state for you really
quelle suprise I was surprised by this I
don't know why he would be nothing about
their interaction has indicated to me
that he would save this amazing
one-on-one date with her and she even
says the power drones are really John
that's okay okay like a little girl's
not another factor that I kind of
figured out tonight re is operating very
much based on attraction and chemistry
instead of conversation how do I know
this because Ari says things like quote
even though I don't know much about her
just spending time with her makes me
really happy what does that mean I just
want this to work so badly that maybe
I'm trying to will it to happen so he's
attracted to her he's going off that gut
instinct but they're having a hard time
talking how do we know that because we
watch them in silence and Ari says
things like look at these wheels of
cheese wheel de fromage great deer says
that it's hard to tell what Ari's
looking tía says that it's hard to tell
what ari is looking for and I agree and
also tia has sort of become the narrator
of this season which I don't carry with
I really like Tia and on that note
people don't be what you think someone
is looking for just be you re and Lauren
beer drinking some wine out of some not
wine glasses hmm then they have this
conversation about the crazy day they
had it was so busy out today - mm-hmm
it's like really busy almost like insane
but yeah that kind of freaked me out a
little bit what what was just the people
walking around the wheels of cheese did
I miss the part where a massive wheel of
cheese rolled through the streets of
Perry and almost killed them both that
would have been insane I can't open up
until I trust somebody
yeah then we have a great moment and I
want to take a minute to get serious
because Ari seems to like Lauren B so
much that he was willing to just drop an
emotional personal bombshell in order to
break that wall between them and connect
with her and he did just that you know I
had my last serious relationship was
with someone who had two kids Ari
reveals that the woman who he dated I
believe before Emily Maynard a woman he
lived with and had kids with became
pregnant with their child what and had a
miscarriage in that then they broke up
this was very real I really respected
Ari for being so honest and open about a
topic that not a lot of people discuss
and then Lauren D is also inspired to
open up and talks about her parents
having a difficult marriage so this was
a real moment and I have been asking Ari
to give us a real moment and now I'm
realizing that this season is a slow
burn along so Lauren B gets a rose and
then we have a group date at the noodle
roof now nowhere in sight were nicole
kidman nor even McGregor which I found
to be very disapoint who had a bit of a
sexual awakening to that movie trust me
okay really opening up and being
vulnerable guys yes so this date today
is definitely for the women Ari says
this date is definitely for the women I
have to disagree because the date seems
to be all about the women wearing really
revealing clothing on display for lots
of people maybe throw in some jazz hands
we're just gonna go through some of the
quotable moments of the night Jenna says
I never thought I would be with the most
gorgeous man alive okay
[Music]
I'm horrible and Tia is trying to learn
the dance and just goes nope nope
they are so naked Becca says I never
want to take this off and other Becca
says I've never been in more pain in an
outfit before see this date is very
polarizing depending on what type of
person you are and Ari says the getting
the rose is not gonna be about your
performance in the thong it's gonna be
about you know his connection great
but the prize that you get when you get
the rose is to perform on stage in the
fall I would not want that I'd be like
maria-paz cut to the ceremony for me
like I am
Becca gets the rose and she's so excited
it's so cute and I love seeing her
genuine emotion and excitement I like
her and the other women are like oh my
god she gets one time with our II am so
jealous again they're like on stage
lip-synching to this song I would I'd be
like take that time Wow no thanks back
to the war boat crystal says she has
been preparing for this two-on-one what
does that mean I'm just hungry so I'm
just gonna anymore energy food crystal
and Kendall are going on a two-on-one in
a French chateau and we've gone from
wheel of cheese - we love guns I don't
know the date is that they're walking
around the Chateau looking at some
historical crap I don't understand what
crystals saying for most of the state
but she's wearing some great white pants
and she looks great
can we communicate through him and when
she's listening to other people I think
to try to convey that she's listening
she does a lot of yeah yeah yeah yeah
you said some things that were not kind
but
yeah like sexy listening like mm-hmm
yeah yeah it's like it's gonna be a pass
for me so crystal and I are your talking
and again crystal takes it one step too
far things are getting better and then
she starts dissing Kendall wondering
when Kendall is on here with me and you
can immediately tell that Ari's like you
know I mean crystal is so sure she keeps
saying it's gonna be her and Arie
together in the end crystal why do you
think you're here this is an elimination
date it's a two-on-one and one has to go
2-1
meenu's oh that's not right crystal
internally to get time with Arie and
Kendall returns after her time to the
pink party that's happening outside the
chateau everything is pink and Kendall
seemingly is gonna use this moment to
like confront Krystal and be like the
voice for all the women and crystal
takes Becca's line for last week what
why are you here and Kendall's like i'ma
tell you I'm here and it's to confront
you you know I can definitely empathize
with you so she sits down and the
problem is that Kendall as much as I
adore her quirkiness jadelle she's not
the person to do this she just keeps
saying and then talking really fast and
um scooching towards crystal on the
couch the pink couch and nothing about
it as a fashion sorry could be waiting
ari comes back in to say he needs more
time on this two-on-one I need more time
more of this awkwardness no no no
[Music]
he didn't need that much more time he's
dinner ended pretty quickly
Kendall gets the rose and crystal is
watching re and like does not seem like
she's getting what's happening she's
just like mmm yeah yeah he leaves and
she is bored this is why I love this
show because even the people who seem
unstable have pearls of wisdom crystal
says she doesn't know what Ari wants
which is one of the themes of the night
there's very really well like a strong
confident woman you want something a
little more tremendous like needs him
this is a question we are all asking
Krystal and I hope to me because I like
you it's gonna be a really big day
Jacqueline gets a one-on-one who is
Jacqueline I'm not sure but we're
getting a one-on-one and I like this
date because Ari pulls up in this cute
little car but then the car breaks down
it becomes very real you know like a
real moment what are you doing the car
breaks down and the answer is that you
vlog in live knulla so Jacqueline is
really smart and funny and cute and I
didn't really know she was until this
moment and then Ari says he really
really likes her and again I'm so
confused like who do you really like and
why and you need clarity look the clown
clown yeah gladly today Thank You JC cut
to the rose ceremony and Ari says Paris
has been amazing Victor Kadare what is
amazing is tias pantsuit shout-out to
TIA she looked great and re cut some
people he cuz Jenna and Chelsea
surprised to see Chelsea go I thought
that Ari and Chelsea had a strong
connection so again I've descended into
the pit of confusion at this point
we don't but Ari reveals something
that's actually amazing after this
they're going to Tuscany okay they're
going to Tuscany and as amazing as that
is I'm getting pissed off by this lot of
things Lauren B looks miss Ruth she
looks so unhappy
okay so Leigh I think my French has
improved is this video it's gone then we
get I believe you
and it does look like Becca with the
long hair sitting and crying on a gray
couch based on you know what she looks
like and this tattoo on her hand and
then at the end we see re sitting on a
great couch while someone is sobbing so
I believe the subber to be wild right
Becca
so that is the end of this episode of
The Bachelor and it was a good one again
I think we're having a slow burn towards
the finish here you guys Chris Harrison
recently told ET but there is going to
be a crazy finish to this season and
granted we are always told it will be
dramatic but he sounded pretty adamant
about it also shameless glove surprise I
had to keep it a secret but I was in
Vermont for winter games it was so much
fun and I interviewed Ben Higgins and
Chris Harrison nationally I can Eddy and
Luke pal and Claire Crawley and some of
the international contestants and Eric
bigger and those are all coming to eat
see online and a slow roll out over the
next week ahead of the premiere of
Winter Games on February 13th on ABC
what a time to be alive
also I had such a fun time filming
bachelor party this is the ringers
bachelor podcast with the wonderful
Juliet Lippmann so please give that a
listen as well we talked about this
week's completion episode and I'm gonna
go have a Sun full mosh back
I also bought this scarf because I sort
of liked and wives look really far and
such unit ly I have eaten a lot of
croissant and so if we can pan down this
is what we are dealing with not very
chic